come and go e5 then
i was gonna go for this stuff again yeah
not thrilled to see it i have to say
i'll just try to do something more or
less common sense i guess
just now good
now good
there's knight f5 here right
and it takes everything
yeah i don't want to do that
oh two and a half points from the last
three is previous
shouldn't be tilting that arch
i'm hoping that tap water that's what
i've been missing
okay we'll take this one
and this
g6 i'll try to go f6
i suppose
you can go e6 but i i don't believe i
should be worried about that
could be wrong
ah he's just lining up the
rooks
okay i don't need all my rooks to get
forked over there so
i guess i'll go with this one
if i do have the time i will play
rook e8 and then knight f8 and his pawn
will be gone so he needs to act
kind of swiftly
or queen b3 is an issue that's something
i'd missed
because i was only thinking of a3 then i
could go
a5 and that looked perfectly fine
um i guess it's time to go knight f4
then
i don't love it though
don't love it okay we go back
h4 i'm hoping that there are no like
particularly nasty tricks
i am threatening rookie 8 pretty pretty
hard here
queen e3 there is bishop a5 and
his pawn is it's gone
so he does need to think of something
[Music]
a3 okay
oh that is a bit stupid now i go bishop
a5 and then
and then rookie i think that was a mess
by him
yeah now this looks very good for me
he's fighting well i have to say i i
could see that this was his only chance
i don't think it's sufficient
g6 he wants knight g2
and obviously i don't want to take an e6
and give him b7
okay so i'll go queen b8 i believe
yeah i think so queen e3 and queen c8
and i don't believe there are any tricks
if 95 knight f5 don't love
allowing that knight over there but i
don't think
i don't think there are any
many tricks
still finding them huh
okay so what i'll do is i'll go queen d8
and force
b4
then his pawn on d4 might be attacked
later
okay g6 now he's not in time for knight
g2f4
so i'm finally winning some of his stuff
i believe
yeah now i'm getting e6
and i'm much much better
it goes 93 now it goes knight f4 don't
believe that was a good one
night queen e1 queen e4 queen d4
and that should be game over
okay he goes queen c2 now but
there should be very few chances for him
okay just don't blunder anything
e4 windy one
i'll just improve my king a little bit
move along
and set those pawns into motion
after all i do have a lot of them
st4 there's one check i think
or
two checks and then i start having my
fun
or do i okay i'll win another pawn and
then i'll think
okay now i get g4 and then i'll mate
oh no i get queen e4 which is made next
so mother something blind i mean